THEIR SHOULDER BECAUSE GOD
FORBID WE NOTICED THAT THEIR
RECEIVERS AREN'T VERY GOOD.
THEY CAN'T ATTRACT GREAT
THROW THE FOOTBALL VERY WELL,
BUT DON'T TELL THAT TO
GENERAL MANAGER ERIC DECOSTA
THAT MAKES HIM A LITTLE BIT
SALTY HERE. HE IS FROM
EARLIER TODAY, BUT WE WANT TO
DISCONTENT WITH OUR WIDE Y
RECEIVERS AND ARE DRAFTING
AND ALL THAT I MEAN BUT IN
GENERAL I LOOK AT OUR RECORD
AND HOW WE WIN GAMES AND HOW
WE PLAY FOOTBALL AND I'M
PROUD OF THE TEAM I KNOW
COACH IS PROUD. I KNOW JOE IS
PROUD. SO WE'VE GOT SOME
REALLY GOOD YOUNG RECEIVERS.
IT'S INSULTING TO THESE GUYS
WHEN THEY HEAR THAT WE DON'T
HAVE ANY RECEIVERS. IT'S
QUITE INSULTING. I'M INSULTED
BY A TO TO BE HONEST. SO I
THINK WE'VE GOT SOME GUYS
THAT WANT TO SHOW EVERYBODY
WHAT THEY CAN DO EXACTLY
MOTIVATION USE ANY AND ALL
SLIGHTS ACTUAL OR PERCEIVED
TO GET THESE GUYS.
HAVE SOME GOOD YOUNG  THEY
RECEIVERS. WHY DO THEY HAVE
GOOD YOUNG RECEIVERS? BECAUSE
THE ONLY WAY THEY CAN GET
RECEIVERS IS TO DRAFT THEM
BECAUSE THE FREE AGENTS DON'T
WANT TO GO THERE SAMMY
WATKINS DID BECAUSE IT'S NOT
LIKE HE HAD A BUNCH OF
SUITORS CLAMORING AT HIS DOOR
JUJU SMITH SCHUSTER TOOK LESS
MONEY TO STAY IN PITTSBURGH
GUYS DON'T WANT TO GO TO AN
BEING THROWN AND THAT'S NOT A
LAMAR JACKSON SLIGHT THAT IS
A RAVENS OFFENSE SLIGHT.
THAT'S WHAT THEY DO. LOOK AT
THAT PASS ATTEMPTS PER GAME
LAST IN THE LEAGUE PASS ROADS.
PER GAME LAST IN THE LEAGUE.
WELL, SOMETHING'S GOTTA GIVE
IS ONLY ONE FOOTBALL AND WHEN
YOU SKEWED TOWARD THE RUN,
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO PASS AND
WHEN YOU DON'T PASS YOU'RE
NOT GOING TO ATTRACT
RECEIVERS TO YOUR TEAM PERIOD
YEAH, EXACTLY. LOOK, I MEAN
RUSHING TEAM. THEY HAD A GOOD
THEY HAVE THEIR QUARTERBACK
GO OVER A THOUSAND YARDS
RUSHING FOR THE SECOND YEAR
IN A ROW THAT'S NEVER
HAPPENED BEFORE SO THERE IS A
REASON WHY THEY ARE STILL
EFFECTIVE ON OFFENSE. IT'S
THE RUN GAME, BUT I THINK
WHEN YOU ARE 30
DEAD LAST IN BOTH PASSING
YARDS AND PASSING ATTEMPTS.
IT MEANS YOU'RE REALLY NOT
EVEN TRYING TO THROW THE BALL
ALL THAT MUCH AND AGAIN WHEN
YOU RUN THE BALL AS
EFFECTIVELY AS THEY DO IT
MAKES SENSE. SO I GET WHAT
THE COST IS SAYING, YOU KNOW,
I'M PROUD OF THE TEAM. WE'RE
COURSE, THEY'RE WINNING GAMES
AND THEY MAY OR MAY NOT BE
THE BEST TEAM IN THAT
DIVISION. I THINK THAT YOU
CAN CERTAINLY MAKE AN
ARGUMENT THAT THEY STILL ARE.
HOWEVER, I THINK TO SAY, YOU
KNOW ALL WE HAVE THESE GOOD
YOUNG WIDE RECEIVERS IN THERE
DOWN AT 58 CATCHES FOR SEVEN
HUNDRED AND SIXTY NINE YARDS
AND EIGHT TOUCHDOWNS LAST
YEAR THAT LED THE TEAM IN
YARDS AND ALSO HE TIED FOR
THE TEAM LEAD AND RECEPTIONS
WITH MARK ANDREWS. AND IN
ORDER TO FIND YOUR NEXT WIDE
RECEIVER ON THAT LIST. YOU
HAVE TO GO ALL THE WAY DOWN
TO WILLIE'S NEED WHO HAD
THIRTY THREE CATCHES FOR 432
YARDS. I'M SORRY. YOU'RE
ERIC DECOSTA, BUT MY MAN THAT
IS NOT EFFECTIVE WIDE
RECEIVING BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT
THROWING THE BALL, SO I
FIND YOU WANT TO BE INSULTED
AND THAT YEAH, YOU MAY HAVE
GOOD YOUNG WHITE OUTS, BUT
YET LEAST GOT TO GET
SOMETHING MORE OUT OF THAT
PASSING GAME MAN. AND
REMEMBER IT WAS HOLLYWOOD
BROWN WHO AT ONE POINT DURING
THE SEASON DURING ONE OF
THOSE STRETCHES WHERE THINGS
WERE GOING. WELL, HOW DID
TWEET CRITICIZING THE WAY HE
WAS BEING USED AND FINALLY
LATER IN THE SEASON THEY
BEGAN TO DEVELOP CREATIVE
WAYS TO GET THE BALL IN
HOLLYWOOD BROWNS HANDS.
THAT'S THE CHALLENGE. IT'S A
CHALLENGE OF COACHING. YOU
GOT ONE FOOTBALL. YOU GOT 11
PLAYERS FIND A WAY TO GET THE
BALL INTO THE HANDS OF
OF ALL OF THE SKILL POSITION
PLAYERS NOT JUST THE ONES WHO
WHO, YOU KNOW ARE GOING TO
GAIN YARDAGE. IT'S LIKE THAT
PLAY IN MADDEN THAT WORKS ALL
THE TIME. YOU JUST KEEP DOING
IT BECAUSE IT WORKS THE
PROBLEM IS YOU COULD DEVELOP
OTHER FACETS OF YOUR OF YOUR
OF YOUR ATTACK AND YOU JUST
AREN'T TRYING BECAUSE IT'S
TOO EASY TO GO WITH THOSE TWO
OR THREE PLAYS THAT WORK ALL
THE TIME. SO WE'LL SEE IF
THEY CAN DO IT THIS YEAR WITH
MARQUIS BROWN ENTERING HIS
THIRD SEASON WITH SAMMY
WATKINS ON THE TEAM. WE'LL
UP, AND ALSO WHOEVER THEY
DRAFT WHO WON'T HAVE ANY
CHOICE BUT TO JOIN THE RAVENS
IN ANOTHER YEAR THAT IS VERY
DEEP AT THE DRAFT POSITION.